today on behalf of the Maltese
presidency I presented our program and
priorities in the areas of Agriculture
and Fisheries agriculture the main
priority would be monitor to monitor the
situation of the markets and ongoing
trade negotiations as well as to make
progress in files such as organic
production the Omnibus proposed
antimicrobial resistance and veterinary
medicines officially the presidency
would work to where the adoption of a
number of key legislative texts cluding
various multi-annual plans external
fishing fleets and technical measures
the minister's acknowledged that there
had been some progress but expressed
concerns at the continuing level of
volatility in several market sectors and
segments especially with regard to dairy
beef and poultry the concert was also
positive about the implementation of the
milk package and its extension beyond
2020 ministers underlined the importance
of trade for agriculture and the
potential economic benefits of FTAs
however they also warned against
unbalanced agreements and expressed
concern about possibility agreements
with direct competitors during a
wide-ranging discussion we paid
particular attention to discussing how
the European Union could help those
affected by recent earthquakes I will
propose that Italy will be able to
provide a national top up of two hundred
percent to the 21 million euro in
European aid that we provided in last
July's support package I'm ready to
respond positively to a request to
extend the areas for which the
Commission has already authorized
advance payments for some direct payment
schemes and allow the payment of certain
rural development measures to be brought
forward